maybe put Hitchcock's head on top like
an angel Wow like that no put it behind
the tree thanks for helping me make this
card you're so good at this stuff I know
I'm good at everything all right so
here's all the pictures of Rosa that we
have which one she is she never smiles
is her mouth broken well what about if
we flip those lips
oh god that's horrifying we have to get
a picture of Rosa's smiling Holt's card
has to be perfect guys I got this I can
make Rosa smile just keep your camera's
ready making coffee can you make another
cup for Senor tickle and there's no way
a amigos I think you sprint Senor tickle
next time I break it off
what do you think g-gonna hired that bi
to mock us she's scared she's not scared
with all due respect sir gina has no
feelings she wants that the best comedy
of all time was the girl with the Dragon
Tattoo well think about how she's been
acting Gina came by my house last night
do I buy an Uzi I asked for a police
officer to escort me to work and it took
a while for dispatch to find me a young
Kevin Costner type our home doesn't feel
safe anymore
if someone broke into your apartment and
you weren't cops wouldn't you be scared
yes depends how many guns do I still
have hidden no do I saw my knife
nunchucks axe it was a hypothetical
question I know but I want to play it
out do I sell my throwing stars this has
taken a strange turn fine I'd be scared
we're on it woman doesn't have an axe
there should be yes you did it they
found him guilty on all charges
huh well as advice worked so where's
your happy place I'm in a cabin in the
middle of nowhere
inside it's just me and that stupid
slimy defense attorney and I'm eating
the hell out of him
hey break a dining room table over his
head then I rip off his arm and shove it
where the Sun don't shine then I reach
down his throat and shake his hand
yeah okay I'm gonna go ahead and
schedule you for a psych eval I owe you
one Boyle Thank You dinner tomorrow
night for baldies it's all-you-can-eat
linguini yes oh my boyfriend's coming to
your what right now Fievel goes west yes
sir
love that little mouse his journey a
story of America I could not agree more
Fievel
Papa Fievel hey coz I'm not his mom put
this stupid braid in my hair
oh it's beautiful yea that's cuz I cute
please have my children alright
everyone's here today we're gonna work
on our courtroom demeanor Pass
the seminar is not optional Diaz you
testifying in an aggravated assault case
tomorrow the DA is worried about how you
present yourself on the stand why I'm
fine on the stand look I'll make this
real simple so even these dum-dums can
understand man did crime I'm sorry can
you make her stop doing that weird thing
with her face crime and when this is
over I'm gonna find you and I'm gonna
break those little fingers miss Diaz
please stop threatening the stenographer
this is an important case you need to do
well fine I'll take your dumbass seminar
that's the spirit you wanted to see me
sir I understand you stopped by the
patrol offices morning briefing yeah
officer deetmore help me out with my
crime scene so I gave him a little
thank-you present hey deetmore you're
gonna bag evidence like a five-year-old
you should have the proper tools - my
first police kit the walkie talkie blows
bubbles
hope you can handle it he mislabeled the
weapon like an idiot and it almost got
filed with the wrong case he could've
won months of work you humiliated
officer deetmore in front of his peers
he submitted an official complaint
against you did he feel it on crayon no
but he did use a green pen which seems
crazy to me
the good news is if you go down there
and apologize you let the whole thing go
fine I'm great at apologizing I'm a very
sweet person
out of my way chunk captain thank you
for joining us what's going on a proper
birthday dinner Amy chose the restaurant
often Oh perfect I've always wanted to
come here boy I'll pick the menu
Vivian helped Terry chose the champagne
I'm sorry about your party sir I tried
to keep them in line but I failed wow
that's not your job I'm only sorry you
two get a chance to enjoy yourself gina
has brought back all the silverware that
she stole from your house what also this
clock good heavens this isn't ours and
my contribution will be to refrain from
discussing the New Yorker for the rest
of my living days enjoy
[Music]
hey there beautiful
Marcus what are you doing here well I
know you lost your phone charger so I
got you a new one yeah I want to make
sure your phone's all juiced up by some
sweet long-distance texting thanks what
do I owe you
it's a gift all you got to say is thank
you I said thank you that was the first
thing I said sorry you're nice I'll text
you can't wait
inappropriate work kiss two-fifteenths
not me
rosid d-mac and down with a boo on this
tree love it
say boo again I will shoot you in the
stomach fine loverboy it is what did I
just say you said what did I just say
not to say all right who's up first
party number one will be brought to you
by Gina linetti and good times we're
exactly all these good times because so
far the first six seconds of your party
are big volts news tonight we will be
attending my nephew Anthony's 13th
birthday party so it's awful teenage
boys are the worst
but shooting them with paintballs and
the behind is the best which is what
we're gonna do it's a paintball party
nice let's go shoot my nephew Gina do
you have any idea what you're getting
into
we play the lead a lead Oh
[Music]
unleash hell
well well well guess I nailed it
pressures on guys good pressures my jam
party round 2 the quiz winner gets a
question mark crown so cool um I'll take
lonely arts and crafts for 800 first of
all I've made many friends through arts
and crafts and how many of them are
googly eyes and secondly it's a drinking
game get a question wrong do a shot oh
and the questions they're all about Rosa
but none of us know anything about Rosa
everyone's about to get real hem roof
what is my favorite soup chicken noodle
potato leek car freaking noodle I mean
Schauder damn it you're all wrong I've
never had soup don't bother they all sec
drink
battle-ax good disembowelment guys I was
a baby my first word was Dada
great
[Music]
wrong I could totally do a handstand
good luck following this party ya bish
all right well you're up where we going
a restaurant specifically that petite :
it means small intestine cuz that's all
they serve neither can anyone else which
is why they shut it down we are not
eating at this restaurant
we are demolishing it madam
may I offer you the first whack been
dreaming about this since I was a little
girl
[Music]
guys love is beautiful drug running
kidnapping murder those are the best
crimes why would you quash them time
from waiting is over now is the time for
groin stomping damn right it is
let's go arrest that punk he says Punk
just like you what do you think he'll
earnest a hunk
you